listen you have to know something yeah
everybody here any human being in this
area on all the world
not against a beat everybody like life
even Hamas in Gaza they like life they
like peace but peace not like what you
want a lot of Sir if I want to buy
something from you if I get it for your
price and I am happy for your things I
will buy it so our situation here what's
going with the Israeli we are not
against of Israel as people Jewish we
are against of occupation if you
remember what's happened with Russia and
okra India
look
one year Russia they have a problem and
they're afraid from NATO come to close
to the going inside okrania all the
world
and all the arming of the world against
Russia how come I am Refugee in my land
why I'm lost my house did I make
something for Israel did I did my Hitler
was my cousin did I make anything for
the Jews in the world me and my family
and the Palestinians do you have hope
for peace
my age is 50 years I have seven kids no
hope if I told I have hope I'm job and
if you want to say the truth there is no
justice in the world
if you are strong
everybody Afraid from you if you are not
everybody
kill you they make you like this by your
foot
that's what happened
there is no peace my friend if you want
to see the peace come to our camp where
I live you will cry
you will cry you see our peace what are
the conditions like
in uh in the camp my friend they're
waiting for water water you know what's
been water yeah in Europe the dog he
lived in good condition dog animals how
come a human being don't have water
water to drink I asked you about anger
What about love you got love in your
heart well I love everybody even the
Jews they kill us they destroyed our
houses I'm not looked to fight I'm not
looking to kill I am against violence we
love your kids to live in good condition
that Israeli side and the Palestinian we
are against the violin we don't want to
see more blood
we want to destroy this wall you come to
me I come to you that's it
That's My Hope thank you my brother
thank you that's pretty good